brian is with us in Rhode Island
hi Brian how are you doing pretty good
days I hope to be speaking with you okay
my wife and I would like the Total Money
Makeover there graduated from Financial
Peace University how we ran baby step
number two we've been in that posture
for the past two years we initially had
$82,000 of student loan debt and we
brought it down to fifty five thousand
now my question for you is we have two
kids
it's real daughter and a one-year-old
son my wife wants to put them in a
private school next year the tuition is
twelve thousand five hundred per child
and so it's going to be twenty five
thousand for both of them to attend 401
and right yeah yeah that's my signing up
I'm I'm so confused what does she think
she's going to get for that with a
one-year-old that's you have an actual
logical explanation for that no she
can't give me anything well don't I
think she can give me that they're a
sponge they're a sponge and it's better
to put them in school at this time
rather than we wait later until a lot of
death okay all right and what's your
household income 50 it's about fifty one
thousand and you're going to spend
twenty five thousand yes well that's
absurd dude even even if it was
absolutely necessary you don't have that
kind of money yep this is illogical you
can't spend that kind of money on your
house yep
you can't spend fifty percent of your
income on your home much less a
one-year-olds tuition so this is so far
it's so illogical and apparently so
emotional that I'm not sure I'm gonna be
able to give you an answer that's going
to work for her I suspect you're gonna
have to get some outside counsel whether
it's your pastor or marriage kind
learn someone else that she trusts to
explain to her that this is playing
straight-up stupid because it is yeah I
mean if she can't I I can't I can't
imagine being able to reason with her if
she ever thought this was a good idea
that's my problem because it's so
irrational it's not even close I mean if
you told me you made 250,000 then we'd
have a different discussion but you make
$50,000 your household income is $50,000
a year and she won't spend $25,000 on
school for a one-year-old no three year
old yeah okay
even if it was for a 12 year old who was
a genius and you could make the sponge
argument then right the kids a savant
and I want to make sure he becomes all
that God has for him to be even if that
was the case you simply can't afford it
that's not the case because it's a
premise is ludicrous by the way so just
as an aside for you people out there let
me help you with this there are zero
data points that indicate private school
1 through 12 there's zero data points
tying that to success 0 0 now there are
some safety factors there's some faith
factors and there can be an increased
academic experience but to say that this
is the only way your child is going to
succeed
there's just no data points that
indicate that none none and it goes all
the way into college by the way for
those of you listening I mean we just
finished the millionaire study right the
ten thousand millionaires 67% of the
millionaires that we studied did not go
to prestige schools they went to state
schools only 8% went to prestige schools
which tells us that it's not necessary
to go to prestige school to become a
millionaire that's what that that's a
causal as a statistic that's causal you
can tell ok so the premise that you have
to go to private school in order to be
successful in this world is ludicrous
now there's no there's advantages to go
into a
it's gone if you wanted to a private
school you know the money to do a
private school that's ok folks I don't
mind that I'm ok with that
I didn't do it my kids didn't do it but
my son-in-law works for a private school
so I'm not mad about private schools
there's nothing wrong with that but but
this idea that somehow your kid is going
to be more likely to succeed no really
not really
there's no data points to say that so I
make a bazillion dollars a year and I
would not spend $25,000 on a one year
old a three year old to go to anything
there's nothing I love my I got
one-year-old grandbabies and three year
old grandbabies and there's no possible
way Papa devs writing that check and I
love those grandbabies more than
anything and they're the smartest kids
on the planet by the way they're Ramsey
so they're brilliant they're absolutely
brilliant but I'm not doing that